hola muy buenas tardes yo soy flor
álvarez y no sé si conocéis la historia
de ese estudiante mal estudiante de
zoología que solo se ha estudiado la
mosca y llega al examen y resulta que le
cae la vaca y dice bueno la vaca tiene
dos cuernos un rabo en el rabo hay una
mosca la mosca dos puntos blah blah blah
blah y cuenta todo lo que sabe bueno
pues a mí me resulta que en el examen me
ha caído recetas extraterrestres
yo soy ingeniera de montes así que hoy
vamos a hablar de recetas
extraterrestres para la salud de
nuestros bosques y vamos a empezar
precisamente por eso por la salud de
nuestros bosques y es que nuestros
bosques son una fuente muy importante de
beneficios para la sociedad beneficios
de tipo económico de tipo social y de
tipo ambiental y además nuestros
recursos forestales son también tienen
un papel
clave en la bioeconomía por una parte
proporcionando todo tipo de es una
fuente de energía que en la actualidad
supone más de la mitad de las energías
renovables de la unión europea y además
nos producen otro tipo de servicios los
servicios ecosistémicos que también son
clave en este momento porque por ejemplo
nuestros bosques nos ayudan a mitigar
los efectos del cambio climático pero
tanto las enfermedades las plagas como
los incendios hacen que esos beneficios
que nos dan los bosques disminuyan y
para tratar de evitar esa disminución es
muy importante hacer gestión forestal y
el primer paso el primer punto en la
gestión forestal es el conocer si una
masa está sana o está enferma
y cuando estamos trabajando a nivel de
árbol individual pues es algo sencillo
aquí podemos ver la imagen de un castaño
que es un árbol pues muy representativo
del bierzo de donde yo vengo y podemos
ver que hay una serie de daños que son
aparentes y que además nos damos cuenta
de que existen cuando lo comparamos con
los castaños que están alrededor que no
tiene ningún tipo de daño entonces
podemos hacer una identificación que
denominamos binaria del daño presencia o
ausencia del daño eso en primer lugar y
una vez que tenemos determinada la
existencia del daño podemos determinar
su intensidad lo que nosotros
denominamos severidad hasta ahí bien
pero las cosas se complican cuando ya
trabajamos a escala de masa cuando
trabajamos a escala de bosque nos surgen
interrogantes como cuántos árboles
tienen que estar enfermos para que
consideremos que esa masa está enferma o
cuál tiene que ser la intensidad de ese
daño para que realmente comprometa el
funcionamiento
de nuestro bosque por eso es importante
contar con sistemas que sean objetivos y
que nos permitan hacer un seguimiento
del estado sanitario de nuestros bosques
y este tipo de sistemas ya existen a
escala europea tenemos por ejemplo la
red de parcelas hay zippy que a través
de a partir de medidas en campo
determina cuánto de sanos o cuántos de
cuánto de enfermos están nuestros
bosques podemos ver los puntos negros
que se corresponden en parcelas de nivel
1 que nos dan información a una escala
poco detallada pero que como vemos
tenemos muchos puntos en la península
ibérica y por el contrario tenemos otro
tipo de parcelas las de nivel 2 que
aparecen en color naranja que nos dan
información mucho más detallada pero que
son menos frecuentes entonces este
sistema está muy bien porque además nos
da información basada en observaciones
de campo pero que puede ocurrir pues que
en la zona en la que yo trabajé no haya
ninguna de esas
o que cuando se han hecho las mediciones
pues esa no sea la fecha que a mí me
interese o que el nivel de detalle que
yo necesito no es el que me proporciona
y cómo solucionamos este problema pues
desde hace más de un siglo estamos
utilizando para el seguimiento del
estado sanitario de nuestros bosques la
observación remota lo que llamamos
observación extraterrestre que nos
permite conocer las características de
un lugar sin estar en contacto cámara
eso es lo que nosotros denominamos
teledetección y tal vez nos haya
sorprendido un poco esto desde hace más
de un siglo
hacemos teledetección pero es que ya en
el siglo pasado hacíamos observación
utilizando plataformas como estas
palomas mensajeras que llevaban de
sensores películas en blanco y negro
pero sin duda ha sido la aparición del
aeroplano en 1903 lo que realmente ha
impulsado a la teledetección
y desde entonces hasta ahora hemos
recorrido un largo camino pasando hace
50 años por la luna en el año 1972 con
ese hito que es el lanzamiento del
programa lanza de observación de la
tierra los primeros satélites concebidos
para uno es un uso civil y precisamente
centrado en la observación de las
cubiertas vegetales y poniendo el punto
y seguido con el lanzamiento hace dos
años de un escáner láser montado en un
satélite que además es de la familia de
estar barrios porque decidieron llamarle
gerais
y
estas son múltiples opciones que tenemos
para hacer observación de la tierra y
hace unos años las previsiones eran que
en 2020 tendríamos unos dos mil
satélites orbitando alrededor de la
tierra y unos 20 mil 20 millones de
drones capturando información pero como
tantas veces la realidad supera la
ficción y ya este año tenemos más de 5
mil satélites activos que lo que suponen
son muchísimas posibilidades de que
nosotros obtengamos información
y cómo funciona esto de la detección
remota la detección remota nos permite
hacer visible lo invisible y por qué el
por qué nuestra fuente de energía que es
el sol emite radiación electromagnética
en longitudes de onda que algunas son
visibles para nosotros y otras no pero
sí lo son para estos sensores con los
que trabajamos entonces esa energía que
es emitida por el sol atraviesa parte de
ella la atmósfera llega a la superficie
terrestre e interacciona con las
cubiertas parte de esa energía es
reflejada y vuelve a atravesar la
atmósfera y ahí llega hasta el sensor
que la captura y transmite a las
estaciones que están en tierra y
transmite esa información almacenada en
forma de imágenes y precisamente esa
información que está en cada uno de los
píxeles de las imágenes es lo que
nosotros denominamos respuesta
espectral y esa respuesta espectral que
tenemos representada en este gráfico es
característica para cada una de las
cubiertas que tenemos en la tierra y por
eso se le denomina también firma
espectral y la suerte que tenemos los
que trabajamos en esto de las de la
detección forestal es que la asignatura
espectral de la vegetación enferma que
aquí aparece en color naranja es
diferente de la asignatura espectral de
la vegetación sana que aparece en color
verde y además donde se diferencia más
donde más se separan esas curvas es en
dos partes del espectro que no son
visibles para nosotros pero sí para la
mayoría de los sensores con los que
trabajamos que son el infrarrojo cercano
y el infrarrojo de onda corta y aquí es
donde vamos a empezar nuestra receta
extraterrestre de hoy y qué ingredientes
tenemos pues esas asignaturas
espectrales esa información que está
almacenada en las imágenes que capturan
los vigías de las
de nuestros montes que son los sensores
y quiénes son los cocineros de esto pues
nosotros los profesores que estamos en
el campus de ponferrada y que trabajamos
en este tema somos los encargados de
transformar esos datos en información
sobre lo sana o lo enferma que está la
masa que estamos estudiando así que
ahora os venís de viaje conmigo hasta
fresnedo a cubillos del sil más o menos
pues a 20 minutos de ponferrada y nos
vamos a observar los daños que causó en
2014 esta oruga que se llama límite
lymantria dispar que en inglés tiene un
nombre pues mucho más divertido que slip
ximo y que a lo que se dedicó pues fue a
de foliar a comerse las partículas de
los pinos lo que supone que luego los
pinos no puedan hacer la fotosíntesis y
que por lo tanto vean comprometidas su
supervivencia estos bosques de la zona
de tres dedos tienen una gran
importancia no sólo desde el punto d
económico sino que también desde el
punto de vista pues social y recreativo
con lo cual se creó una gran alarma bien
nosotros conseguimos con imágenes del
sensor lanzar que tiene un tamaño de
píxel de 30 x 30 metros y son imágenes
gratuitas de la lanza de de la nasa con
imágenes de antes y después de ese
ataque cartografiar determinar los
límites del ataque como un error menor
del 3 por ciento pero qué ocurre que
estas imágenes de este sensor no tienen
el nivel de detalle ni espacial ni
temporal suficiente para reconstruir lo
que fue el avance de esa plaga que
estuvo actuando varios años entonces
para eso utilizamos de forma
complementaria imágenes de otro sensor
del sensor rápida y rápida y tiene un
tamaño de píxel de 5 x 5 metros de
imágenes que se capturan con una mayor
frecuencia temporal y gracias a eso y
con un índice de vitalidad que se
visualiza en color verde para la zona
que estan vegetando muy bien y el color
azul para las zonas muertas pudimos
identificar la zona y el momento en el
que se originó el ataque y ver el modus
operandi de esta plaga que era la
primera vez que realmente estaba
atacando a las masas de pino radiata en
manos de todo el mundo con esta
intensidad y aquí pudimos ver como al
principio pues los daños parecían que se
iban recuperando que se iba recuperando
la masa pero al final todas estas zonas
que veis en azul que superan las 200
hectáreas se tuvieron que cortar porque
realmente los pinos estaban tan tan
dañados que no consiguieron recuperarse
del daño esta información para que es
fundamental para cuando nos tengamos que
volver a enfrentar a otro evento de este
tipo
y
con esto llegamos al al final de esta
pequeña recetas en la que hemos visto
como los sensores remotos pueden
resultar de gran utilidad para detectar
para monitorizar y para entender cómo
afectan las plagas y las enfermedades a
nuestros bosques y aunque en la
actualidad pues tenemos métodos ya muy
avanzados para lo que es el análisis y
el procesamiento de las imágenes todavía
tenemos muchos retos pendientes como por
ejemplo utilizar toda esta información
para la detección temprana de los
ataques de plagas y enfermedades y
también utilizar toda esa información
para saber exactamente quién es el que
está causando el daño entonces estos son
los retos que nos planteamos y que se
resolverán en los próximos años y
mientras tanto las universidades los
centros de investigación
las empresas y los propietarios pues
estaremos compartiendo ciencia campo y
laboratorio para que esto llegue a buen
puerto y además para que estas
herramientas sean muy útiles para
aquellos que están gestionando las masas
para que puedan tomar decisiones que
hagan que nuestros bosques sean más
resilientes y que además sigan siendo
una cuenta de beneficios y de bienestar
y con esto he llegado al fin de la
receta de hoy en este recorrido que
hemos hecho por la utilidad que tienen
los sensores remotos para cuidar de
nuestros bosques así que espero que os
haya gustado y os aproveche y muy buenas
tardes
[Aplausos]